σε πάρα πολλά πράγματα μπορώ να σας πω ότι έχουμε αναλύςει εργα του τη ιανούν
του ελκρεκο έργα που ήταν στων πενάκια άλλον συλεκτν καιλιπά όπου ανακαλύψαμε την υπογραφεί του
ελκρόικο σεδο από φανωμενικά μηποραμε πράγμα τα οποίο είνες που δέο δε μικρό επίσης μας
έχουν καλές η η τη βενατία να δούμε ταγράφει τη στην εκλησία το γίου μάρκου
όπους ξέρεται ο άγιος μάρκος είναι το σύβολο τς βενατίας κιο άγιο στης βεθενσίες τι
έχιναι μεγάλητιμή πραγματικά που τοδικόμασυ στηδούτ το καλέσανκι έρα έχουμε συνεργαστεί επίσης από με τη
σύρα δυσανδορίνει με τον κύριο τυν μεδούμα με συχορίταί το κύροούμα ι ανακάνουμεδουλειά επάνουν στης
χαμένες ζωγραφίες στην αλεξάνδρια έχουμεκάνει έργο και γενικά προχωρεί το το υστητούτο με ολούς τρόπους
και σε πολλούς τόπους η ελλάδα δεν έχει ένα τέτοιο εδαστήριο και δουλεύουμε τώρα με
τημετο μουσιοβενάκι ια πολλά πράγματα που τους εδιαφέρο ση και συλλογία έργομως σην τροφέργου των
κυριοδ